hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to exhortable money now the
name of this game may seem a little
strange but this game is actually the
prequel to presentable liberty you know
that game that changed my entire
perspective on life and reality well
this is the one that came first it may
be a little weird to call it a prequel
because this came first and presentable
liberty is actually a sequel to this
game either way made by the same guy
and apparently i play as dr money you
know that evil bastard from the first
game who caused the illness that
destroyed everything
what is this
that destroyed everything and oh hey
money money
money
i got money
i don't know how to play this game all i
know is that the the video is a little
trippy kind of hr gigger-esque
okay
whoa
money's just flying out of the box
that's awesome what does this do oh
wow
i can make more money so anyway this
game is kind of a lot like cookie
clicker and it seems really simplistic
and whatnot that's cause it is probably
and it may be slow going because i know
that the pace of presentable liberty was
a little bit slow so i understand that
this one is probably going to be slow as
well so in the meantime where it's going
to take a long time to make money
because i gotta make more money everyone
wants a big boy bye
i'm going to be waiting so like cookie
clicker if you don't know what cookie
clear is my god don't look it up don't
please dear god don't i don't want to
lose another to the the internet i
played that game till i got trillions
and trillions and quintillions of
cookies god that game ate away in my
life and i'm not saying that this one is
also going to eat away in my life but
hey money is probably everything money
is everything that i need to make
happiness in the world money will
survive through all troubles
now i don't know if if on here like all
these questionable things like i know
what happened in presentable liberty if
you didn't understand what happened
exactly in presentable liberty dr money
he had a scheme to make more money and
that was to create a virus
that would cause people to buy his cure
if you create a virus and create a cure
this thought concept this idea has been
presented in the world like it's already
a real world idea it's totally morally
wrong in every sense of the word and
completely illegal it would be horrible
to do but if you could get away with it
you would create a need for a product
while at the same time creating such a
fervent need that everyone would want to
buy it or everyone would have to buy it
or else they would die
like create a lethal enough virus that
would cause people to want your damn
cure and then sell
the cure at whatever price you want you
would literally make all the money in
the world and that's like
that that that's the idea behind a lot
of conspiracy theories like the united
states or the medicine industry they
made certain viruses they didn't i'm not
saying they did i
i'm not saying anything at all i'm not a
conspiracy theorist but i'm just saying
the theories exist that it's like people
say the possibility that it could happen
exists oh mail i got mail
madam sinclair
hello hi
thank you
i guess
i got bill's version two
okay
all right i am madame sinclair
thank you madam sinclair
i am so glad you stopped by to send me
that one damn letter
what was the purpose if you don't mind
me asking excuse my theatrics i feel
like i should be fancy i'm just gonna
have to wait a bit longer but anyway
what was i saying um
oh yeah i'm not a conspiracy theory this
is exactly what i was going i am not a
conspiracy theorist i am not the game
theorist i am nobody except for
markiplier or known as mark and i sit in
a room alone talking to myself playing
video games but
there are these theories and these ideas
and the thought games are there and it's
interesting to ponder these ideas but
the the resulting chaos is like exactly
what happened in presentable liberty
like the horrific situation of it all
going wrong is exactly what happened and
the weird thing is like it presented the
worst case scenario but also the worst
person scenario to possibly do it and to
explore the idea that if you're morally
you know if your morals are low enough
such that you would even contemplate let
alone execute the plan of creating a
virus and then creating a cure and
making people buy it at an incredible
price
then
i guess that same person would have no
problem with
selling organs to try to also cure your
stupid disease that you created that's
killing everybody in the entire world
and
ripping this guy apart but then again it
might have all been a thought idea and
maybe none of it in presentable liberty
was real and maybe all of this is just
an illusion crafted l oh so elegantly by
the government and they're just trying
to get at us yeah yeah whatever i don't
know i think i'm getting close to buying
another bills version three god this is
going to take a while because i don't
even think i have a way to like click
like i don't think me clicking
does anything like
i'm pretty sure
it just do by itself but maybe hang on
oh another letter from madame sinclair
hmm
i see you are making money yes of course
i'm making money ah anything can make
money with the right oh yeah
okay
i'm trying to click but i i really don't
think it do
do it do is this making wait
oh i think it do wait
i might it might just be the placebo
effect
i want to say that this is making me
more money
but i don't know i want more lettuce
from madame sinclair also i want to move
this goddamn story forward there's gonna
be a lot of jumps it's come to my
conclusion that my clicking is doing
absolutely dick diddly so i shouldn't
even bother i might as well take a
bathroom break while i'm waiting for all
this to go down but my next purchase is
going to be the little kitty cat because
if you look the kitty cat costs a
thousand dollars i don't know what the
kitty cat is going to be for but knowing
this game is probably going to be
horrible and scar me for life so warning
everybody you're about to have your
heart broken all over again
actually i don't know maybe this game is
literally just cookie clicker and
there's no hidden meaning to it but
knowing that it's sending me letters i'm
a
little
oh here we go here we go
i got a little itty bitty clicker cat to
look for money bye bye kitty you'll be
good you'll be good kitty come back safe
madam sinclair i used to make money too
thanks sinclair
that's so helpful to me
what can you do to help me make more
money because that's all i care about
unless you're going to tell me that
money isn't everything in the world well
then screw who you
i don't care
bing bong i have enough to buy coins
whatever that means i miss my kitty wow
oh that's delightful that's a lot of
coins that's speeding things up
considerably screw the kitty cat i don't
screw the kitty cat this kitty cat found
2 000 monies
oh bye bye kid again i wanted you to
stay a little bit longer so that i could
pet you but i've got all this money who
needs friends when you have money good
god that is a lot of coins or is that
ever am i wrong here but this seems like
an easy game what can i do next i guess
i can get more bills but the bills
actually weren't what were really doing
it for me i think the coins are gonna be
the one to go i'm going to save up a
little more until i can get the coins i
mean my kitty cat found 2 000 bucks
got it good
well it won't be much longer now
till something happens maybe madame
sinclair is going to send me another
letter when i get to three thousand
which is going to be right about
now yay
madame sinclair
oh let's see what madame sinclair wants
to say to me are you my oh don't play
this bowl with me i don't have the
emotions for it i can't tolerate this
sort of stuff are you my friend i'm
gonna say no
no
absolutely not i don't know who you are
lady and i'm not gonna care about you
even though you're gonna send me letters
and force me to care no madam sinclair i
have to draw the line somewhere
i don't know you i
just
okay all right okay i'm just gonna wait
for my kitty cat to get back and move on
with my life
yay oh my god kitty found 4 000 monies
oh you're such a good kitty i wish i
could love you but i kind of want you to
go get more money because the longer you
wait here the less time you have to go
find me money so get going kitty itty
bitty kitty oh man i have a lot of money
now i think the best upgrade would be
the money machine because then it would
make all this come faster
so
oh i could buy a background i don't know
what that does but if there's anything
like the cat maybe it'll make me more
money
yay oh
that's not yay at all
oh that's not yay either this better be
all thumbs and then some of those ben
that's actually kind of pretty
okay i think i'll take this one
kind of like the sun setting on humanity
as i plot ever so deviously to destroy i
didn't need to buy the bathrooms at all
did i i um
that was a waste of 8 000 monies wasn't
it damn it and sinclair didn't even send
me a goddamn message
i think i better go i'm gonna go get
some food or something it's taking a
while
i actually switched to this one because
it's kind of easier on the eyes so maybe
it'll be easier for you guys to watch i
don't know maybe in the comments below
it's gonna be a big war about which
background i should have chosen and how
i'm so wrong about my life but this is
what it is for now so please bear with
it
oh
kitty's back i don't know why i'm so
happy well of course i know why i'm so
happy getting back you're such a good
kitty you can stay a little bit longer
this time because i missed you it gets
kind of lonely in here when i'm just
waiting for money to collect okay so i'm
gonna get another money machine
oh i can get more coins too but let me
read my mail oh madame sinclair
that was blank
it was blank madam sinclair
i'm not your friend maybe she heard me
all right kitty go find more money cause
i'm gonna need it uh
that was weird
oh yay madam sinclair is back i guess
sorry i forgot to write something on my
last letter oh thank you this one is so
filled with content i am so glad that
you got back to me to remind me that you
didn't send anything on the last letter
how could you forget something like that
are you suffering from a terrible
disease
no all right then i guess this is the
waiting game again at least i'm getting
money more quickly now i need money to
support more for my estate to take care
of all my horrific appetite of [ __ ]
i just realized if you look at the
bottom of the money machine it looks
like two eyes are staring at me like i
don't know how long that's been there
but it's either two eyes or nipples like
either one it could go either way in
that regard either way i'm going to
stare at them
those are eyes definitely eyes
i get so happy when you come back kitty
i'm just so lonely when you're not here
oh ten thousand oh my god i was i was
hoping it was gonna be that much because
now i can afford the topaz is yeah
wow
holy crap that's a lot of topazes okay
kitty i'm sorry but you're gonna have to
go look for more money because i need
more money i need more oil
if i'm going to survive in this world i
need more
all right back to my lazing about
ah it feels good
it's been a while since my kitty cat
returned
hope he's okay
like i i wasn't keeping track of the
time when how far away he was gonna be
hope he comes back
don't know where he goes to find all
that money so maybe
okay now i'm starting to get a little
worried because
it's been a long time now
cat hasn't come back
i asked i never really thought about
where he was going
for howie's getting all that money
my cat comes back
i know what this game is doing
i know it's trying to dick with me i'm
not not dumb even though there's a guy
you know this came before the other one
i i guess i could buy another money
machine i was hoping to save up for a
topaz but that's gonna take a while
why better than i get a money machine
anyway this means faster money
hello madam sinclair
do you want to learn about a new way to
make money yes sure
i hope it's not the idea i'm thinking
you're thinking of because that idea
ain't good
that ain't good i guess i could buy the
coins it's gonna be a while for the tin
can anyway by the bills
what do you got for me madam sinclair i
suck don't you dare
you stay away from the cat
you stay away from that cat will you
tell me where the cat is because i
haven't seen him for a while it's been a
long while since i've seen my kitty cat
i'm just trying to progress the story a
bit here
did you know that cats have more uses
than you would expect
other than finding money
ah how would they possibly have another
use provide finding me money
please tell me
i wouldn't expect them to have all them
and he uses period but hey i'm intrigued
you have my curiosity so let's go for it
now
while i wait for my money to collect
into my pockets
i miss my kitty cat yes i do
i miss my kitty cat don't you two
what did you do with him i'll kill you
no i won't but i'll create a virus and
then create a cure and sell it to the
people who got infected by my virus and
then the whole world is gonna die
bills
oh come on lady get back to me where's
my cat
what did you do with my cat
where's my goddamn cat
i missed my cat
i missed my cat he was the best cat i
wish he was back today
maybe then he will see the life that he
missed and then i'll feed him
once because i haven't since i got him
oh it turns out i'm a bad cat daddy and
i shouldn't be allowed to have cats
my name is dr money and i don't know how
to play the ukulele blah blah blah
i
wanna
see my kitty cat
this came back
it went away for a little bit my cat's
not here
at least i can buy more topazes or
whatever the hell the tin can does
like if i buy the topaz i know it's just
gonna be more money
then again more money is good right more
money is great
more what is
ah
you can sell your kids fur for lots and
lots of money
my i'm welcome
oh my god
no
just put your cat's body into the
machine and
voila
that's not okay
oh
oh
what's worse is i'm gonna do it
oh
oh that's so horrible
why is that a thing
oh
oh
why is that a thing
oh
i'm legit like
really upset at that
that was horrible
that was flip dick and horrible
oh my god
there i was worried about my cat and you
freaking killed it and then i'm
i'm putting i'm making uh
here i thought the game was gonna make
me care about the letters but then again
you know it's like
oh my god madam sinclair you are an evil
evil person
god
that sucks so bad my cat
oh
she had to put the letter of the cat oh
god
i didn't even name him
i didn't even name him
i didn't even name him
oh i can't name him now because he's
gone
i'm making money off of him
ah god what would i have named him i'll
let you guys name him because i'm
obviously too much of an evil person to
name him
and why is that a thing
i guess i'll get more cat fur once i'm
done with this one or maybe a tin can
will be good
i don't even know what the tin can does
oh it's game
see what it does ah why not
oh god more mail what the hell does it
can do
see you're making so so much money now
great
what
what's it
is that literally it
it's a tin can
and i bang on it
that's it
oh wow
there's no point to that
there's no point there's no point any of
that there's no point to having that
oh
okay
more cat fur
oh boy more mail from madame sinclair
whoa
i wasn't dr money
from the desk of dr money
i regret to inform you of a recent new
east-west conflict to rising in the
interest of the economy we ask you
kindly
for money
what how am i supposed to give you money
and why would i give you money dr money
you're more evil than i am
i thought i was dr money wait a minute
what's up mate right here
tell me right yeah
i don't like this
well i didn't like it before but now i
like it even less
gonna wait it out it's gonna way to
wait it out
okay i got a lot of money again
ah come on that didn't do anything
uh how much cat fur do i need to put in
there my poor kitty cat it wasn't even
like an adult kid he was a little baby
and i sent him out to get money
who does that and what cat would do that
that was a gift
it's a glorious gift
i guess i could buy more
stuff money machine blam yay i did it i
did the good thing
what else you got for me
from the desk of dr money that looks
like a guy screaming up there
just send us a letter with the money so
the economy can breathe new air and
breathe new money we are waiting who am
i who the hell am i that you're gonna
ask me and what is this obscure vague
ball you send us a letter with the money
whatever money i want to send so the
economy can breathe new air and breathe
new money
we're waiting well good sir i hate to
inform you that all this money is mine i
had to sacrifice a very lovely cat to
get it and for some reason he had an
unlimited supply of fur blood and
whiskers along with topaz
don't know what money machine i have but
it's glorious
what do you want
madame sinclair
why aren't you replying to my letters
okay this is a presentable liberty
situation i'm in a room alone
or a ukulele i'm in a room alone
and i can't do anything to send you a
letter i don't know how and the game
maker decided that this is how this
should be
so maybe you should just
deal with it
i guess
oh another letter good
we have noticed a distinct lack of you
sending us money for the good of the
economy
the east-west conflict has spread
to the far east now oh no
thanks to me who am i
who who am i
who am i
who the hell am i what the hell is the
east-west conflict and those poor east
bastards and those poor rich west
bastards the poor all of the bastards i
don't know
what the hell is happening
well i sure am getting a lot of money
now
maybe i'll get more cat fur
oh no letters good that's just what i
wanted
is there anything else i can buy
anything at all maybe something to
advance the story a bit oh look i
advanced the story a bit
from the desk of dr money consider this
your last warning if you continue your
incompetence you will be missed by who
who's gonna miss me apparently i have no
friends madam sinclair has like
killed my cat and i don't know what i'm
supposed to do she's obviously not my
friend and you aren't either only money
is my friend
okay
blam
all right what else you got madame
sinclair i even helped you make more
money and still you are ignoring me
please reply
m
s
no you killed my cat and even though i'm
using his fur to make more money that's
your fault not aunt
in closing this letter you will find a
deadly
you can buy the an antidote
this is how it all started you can buy
an antidote in the shop for money
how much money oh only all of my money
no
sir not gonna happen i'm gonna keep all
of my money i don't care if i die
i keep my money
yes
i can buy another upgrade of cat fur i
can't buy a money machine yet
there's a lot of stuff that i want to
buy but i'm not going to buy that
antidote because screw him
hey look at that alrighty
madame sinclair
fine goodbye fine goodbye i guess thanks
for killing my cat
uh what else can i buy bills yes ah yes
oh doctor money yes we have noticed that
you have not bought the antidote yet we
are obliged obligated to remind you that
failing to buy the antidote
might result in death
well
too bad for you
i'm not giving you my money bury me in
all my money it's mine forever and ever
even though i'm kind of also being
buried in my dead cat's fur
but that's beside the point at least i
have my manner
topaz
mail it's mail time mail time
the east-west conflict has ended there
are not enough people left to fight for
the respective cardinal direction in
light of these new circumstances we have
lowered the price of the antidote oh
thank you al oh thank you how good for
you i'm still not gonna buy it you you
didn't lower the oh he lowered the price
by like a thousand oh you dick bag oh
you bag of ass or maybe you didn't
yeah you dick bag you bag of asses this
is my little screw you
boo
you okay anyway moving on
my extreme maturity is gonna guide me
through this game don't you worry
everybody i'm gonna make it through ow
ow
all right time for a money machine bloop
oh no mail well screw all of you i
didn't need you anyway i just need my
money and this stupid freaking antidote
that i'm not gonna buy
not gonna buy it
i don't know if there's an alternate
ending where if you buy the antidote
something happens but i imagine that's
not the case he'll probably just send
you a letter that says you didn't send
enough money and what's probably gonna
result out of this is that he's gonna
release a virus to everyone
i don't know god is so messed up because
this directly correlates i thought i was
dr money because all of all of this
money that i was getting dr money is
just trying to screw everyone else out
of their money i didn't do a damn thing
i was just trying to make money
i didn't kill my cat
i'm just a victim of circumstance i just
happened to use my cat for more money
he was dead
damn doctor money has been pretty silent
is nothing gonna happen unless i buy
that damn antidote because if i do i'm
gonna do when i have like two cents i'm
not gonna give him much
not gonna give him much
i'm gonna buy the topaz and if i don't
get a letter
i'll buy it whoa
whoa oh no
oh no you did not
thank you for your business
thank you very much for screwing me over
are you still alive yes god where'd all
these letters come from all i know about
you is your address i don't know how you
got that in the first place but it's a
slew of action right now
perhaps it's time i came to visit you
all of my family has succumbed to the
deadly
oh no
it's not a prequel it's happening at the
same time
oh no
we forget to inform you that the
antidote is not working as intended
the antidote seems to not only stop the
virus but also prevent the functioning
of various vital organs we have a new
business offer for you we will buy any
and all vital organs people can give us
we have noticed that the organs you are
supplying to us are of sub-optimal
quality due to their organs being a
strange magical money machine
their origins anyone who gets an implant
dies after two hours have passed
okay
due to this inconvenience we can now
only sell them at a low price we hope
you can rectify this as you by maybe
selling us some of your family and
friends
organs
oh why
oh the humanity
is horrifying
i'm sorry i've not come to visit yet
money is slim and the organs are
becoming increasingly expensive
oh
why
why is any of this anything
why is all of this anything
ah
what the hell
what the hell everybody
god damn what's come next
okay nothing i i hope they already oh
boy
i have so much money
this is users to buy more money
hey look mail oh i literal oh i've maxed
out
my money machine
good nice tin can thanks
what
thank you i guess i don't know
the hell
it's a great tin can
it's the best tin can
in all the land
uh
uh
look my mail yay
sinclair this will be my last letter to
you i cannot find the money to buy
working vital organs so i'll have to
settle with the cheap ones
why do you need to keep buying them this
horrible
oh
it was very wonderful dude oh god now
you're gonna make me feel bad but i
don't cause you killed my cat
you killed my cat
oh blame dr money but also i blame you
i blame this magical money machine that
i have that just continually pumps out
more and more money
i love money
but not that much
hello we have a gift for you oh
where is it
where is it
huh
where is it where is this gift is it
money i love some money
but give me
more money
is it money
but before we can reward you we need to
be certain that your production is top
notch
oh so you need to make sure i max out
everything is that your thing
well
wow
i can't even see my mouse really anymore
we will contact you once again your mach
once your machine is fully upgraded i
hope you will survive until then
maybe i won't
i don't know man
dude i just don't know i just want to
ride this one out
during this time i've been playing this
for about an hour and 30 minutes and
during this time i've been responding to
comments on the video that i posted this
morning hooray
well i mean yay for responding to
comments but holy crap this game has
been going on longer than presentable
liberty did blam
kabloom
and
just a little more and i'm oh wait ah
damn it
it's a little more and i'm almost done
ah save
oh i just looked up and realized i had
six million dollars so i think that
might be enough money if i only could
find my mouse there i am blam
blam bloom i did it from the desk of dr
money yes what what is it you bastard we
have noticed that you now have upgraded
your machine to its full potential now
we need you to make more money
lots and more money
thanks everybody in the world is dead
we are maine
how much longer do i have to wait you're
such a son of a [ __ ]
you're such a piece of poop
whatever
whatever how much how how much money
i'll just wait i'll wait oh oh oh oh oh
oh i did it i did it whoa
oh boy
look in the shop for your gift all you
have to do is give us all your money
well
i don't think that's gonna be a problem
seems that my money machine only is
bouncing around one last heart
and there it goes all right
can opener
for my 10 can
thank you for your business as you have
no money now you're considered worthless
to us great for that reason we will
cease all contact with you enjoy your
can opener i will so i just need to get
okay take this
using the can opener you bought with the
last of your money you opened the tin
can
it contained beans
yum
yum yum yum yum yum in my tomtom
you your face lit up and you started
eating
the next day you could feel your organs
starting to fail
you
and at the end of the week
you were dead
what
oh man
ah
i feel like all of my efforts were
worthless madame sinclair was never seen
again i'm guessing because she along
with everyone else in the world
died
dr money continued to make more money
and was considered the richest person
alive
until he too died from the virus he
created yeah suck it dick
that's what you get
that's what you get
god this is so weird this all took place
at the same time at presentable liberty
it's so weird it's so weird to think
about but this is all in the same vein
it's all happening at the same time but
i don't even understand who i was or why
it was happening
it's like
money lives through all things
presentable liberty like took
the human look took the human point of
view of this story like it's like the
developer made this game and then had an
idea to tell it in a different way
because i don't even know who i was
ah the cat ah the cat
i care about the cat more than anything
i don't care about the money
uh everyone died and everyone's sad but
the cat at least didn't have to die of
the virus oh but the cow is brutally
murdered by madame sinclair
i just don't care about her because she
killed my cat
ah
either way i played this for an hour and
45 minutes
hope you guys enjoyed the cut down
version there's obviously a lot taken
out of this but just
thank you all so much for watching
oh okay
hope you all have a great day hope you
all have a great night forget the
horrible memories of this game series
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
i can't move
oh